Donald Trump has finally been vindicated
after months of talking about voter
fraud committed by undocumented
immigrants
saying before the election that it was
rigged saying that 3 to 5 million quote
illegals voted for Hillary Clinton of
course and vowing to conduct an
investigation
we finally pat have a known instance of
an undocumented immigrant illegally
voting and messing messing things up for
Donald Trump oh wait except that this
was a Republican Rosa Maria Ortega a
green card holder outside of Dallas was
convicted of voting illegally in
elections in 2012 and 2014 two felony
charges 37 year old mother of four was
brought to the US as an infant says she
believed she was eligible to vote still
received an 8-year sentence a very harsh
sentence her lawyer said this is a woman
who has a sixth grade education her
lawyer said she can own property she can
serve in the military she can get a job
she can pay taxes but she can't vote and
she didn't know that sometimes
convictions like this don't even result
in jail time and the prosecution didn't
offer any motive for her illegal vote
her original her charges were originally
arranged to be dropped but the court
vetoed the deal insisted on prosecution
Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton says
this shows how serious Texas is about
keeping its elections secure this is a
political move isn't it Pat they're
making an example out of her of course
in a way it backfires relative to
Trump's narrative because this is a
Republican voter
yeah Trump has to continue to prop this
up because he can't shake the fact that
he lost the popular vote by three
million nearly yeah I love their
business assumption that there's not
only voter fraud but it's all being
perpetrated by Democrats I mean right
there was significant examples of voter
fraud it would all be against Trump this
is indeed a registered Republican who in
2012 voted for Mitt Romney for president
in 2014 she voted for Ken Paxton for
Texas Attorney General the man that
actually ended up advocating for her
prosecution and conviction
so yes Donald Trump is right we have
found one instance of this of course it
wasn't during the 2016 election and it
was perpetrated by a row
looking in Texas not someone that would
be hugely likely to vote for Hillary
Clinton in 2016